es ist zeit für einen neuen blog und
dieses mal sind wir in london also let's
go das schicksal meinte es wieder sehr
gut mit mir
denn auch wie in new york lag mein hotel
wieder mitten in der asian china und
korea ecke der stadt und in kombination
mit harry potters diese stadt einfach 10
von 10
aber zurück zur story wir waren also in
london und die erste regel die ich
gelernt habe
man läuft einfach über straßen keiner
achtet auf die ampel das im stil der
gotik gehaltene kirchengebäude stammt im
wesentlichen aus der zeit von 1220 bis
1420 da fühle ich mich zu hause
[Musik]
wir gehen jetzt zum euro marke da gibt
es flohmarkt und lifestyle
das ist der borough market der leider am
sonntag geschlossen ist richtig rein
geschliffen irgendeine travel seite hat
gesagt ist das auch am sonntag auf heute
er hat sogar geschrieben
an einem schönen sonntag im november
sind wir zum baumarkt gefahren in
klammern b hatte dann leider zu von so
einer niederlage haben uns natürlich
nicht runterziehen lassen unsinn zur
national gallery gegangen war gab es
ganz viele bilder dame baby und schöne
architektur und bilder mit bäume und
kaputte bilder und schneebilder und
vincent van gogh hat auch mal ein paar
sonnenblumen gemalt und er hat auch mehr
gemahlen die frau auf den falsch herum
und das bild ist wirklich mein absolutes
lieblings bild gewesen es war riesengroß
und ich weiß nicht was mich daran so
fasziniert hat das experiment mit dem
vogel in der luftpumpe ist ein ölgemälde
aus dem jahr 1767 oder 1768 von josef
reidt of derby das die durchführung
eines vakuumpumpen experiments von
robert ball zeigt und von so viel kunst
bekommt man einen bärenhunger also sind
wir zum rahmen essen gegangen doch
vorher hat uns david beckham ein paar
bei tricks gezeigt
der ender der standard
[Musik]
das wichtigste ist die brühe
dieser rahmen seiten new york haben wir
von guten rahmen geträumt und gott waren
die lecker
[Musik]
falls ihr mal in london seit geht auf
jeden fall zu schoko rahmen und dritte
war dann der sonntag und an dem ins bett
gegangen denn am nächsten tag muss ich
unbedingt los und den adventskalender zu
kaufen
den adventskalender gibt es nur bei
boots zu kaufen leider wird der online
nur innerhalb der uk versendet deswegen
mussten wir natürlich nach london oder
erste laden hat schon mal rein
geschissen ja laden nummer zwei
ich hab ja der witz und dreimal dürft
ihr raten würde einen länger zurück zu
es gab ein
acht minuten fährt und 16 und ich habe
mich natürlich nur für den mit sechs
minuten entschieden
aber der einkommen garten habe
glauben wieder 20 minuten
20 minuten als 100 bands kann man aber
an allem das positive sehen soll habe
ich mich darüber gefreut dass wir eine
neue ecke von london entdecken konnten
also jetzt kaufe ich mir bist du gute
dinge
sie hat mir nicht viel gewöhnt haben sie
halte es auch erste harry potter waren
jetzt über eine schon unterwegs wie die
erkenntnis dass es ab heute zu kaufen
geht aber natürlich kriegen sie es
irgendwie erst heute abend und morgen
früh ostern alles in den regalen im
hintergrund sehen sie bauarbeiter die
für die affen ganze zeit im jahr schon
mal die strafen dekorieren es ist super
nes und super fanny und ja würde david
und deutsche sprache alle drei haben
sich umgedreht die an uns vorbei
gelaufen damit wir an diesem tag
überhaupt noch etwas zum lachen hatten
sind wir in ein comedy club gegangen
[Applaus]
und das war tag 3
kaffee ist das anscheinend hier sinne
kaffeekette ich habe tatsächlich nicht
viele starbucks gewesen wir sind dann
doch zu brettern
und dort haben wir uns so richtig
gegönnt einen ginger schott gegen die
erkältung einen frischen leckeren rap
für die kraft und schön karottenjeans
obendrauf abgerundet mit einem lecker
schmeckt doch als ich dann gesehen habe
was für ein müll unser frühstück
produziert habe ist mir das gleich
wieder hochgekommen merry christmas von
preda wir vermögen die welt und wenn ich
jetzt in den kommentaren leser aber wenn
es doch schon vorher gesehen dass alles
aus plastik ist ja aber ich habe nicht
darüber nachgedacht manchmal denkt man
nicht darüber nach was man tut und dann
erst wenn die aktion vorbei ist sieht
man seinen fehler ein okay leute fehler
werden gemacht also entspannt euch
nachdem wir gestern zu drei geschäften
gelaufen sind wusste hingeben sollte
haben herausgefunden dass er nicht
richtig aufgestellt wurde
also hat mir der verkäufer ein tipp
gegeben bestelle ich ihn in den laden
hinein und hole ihn einfach ab und es
ist so genial und das habe ich gemacht
und jetzt sollen wir nach der große
moment war gekommen
fortsetzung folgt nein spaß
o
[Musik]
wow das ist so schade dass ich hier auf
mache ich würde in rieti auf 1 kalender
benutzen wollen und jetzt kann man ja
auch wieder nach hause fahren
[Musik]
der block der geht weiter ob es euch
jetzt passt und nicht ss obst im haus
wir haben nämlich noch so einiges in
london anzuschauen und zwar genau der
ball marketer vorher zu hatte
dieses geschäft mit der weihnachtstage
diese für den mégane ein wunder dass man
sich so gestresst für die stadt sagt
glaube ich laut s
wieder gelingen
war es doch wieder
die kapelle st wollen wir waren gegen
die lautstärke bekommt ihr jetzt ein
paar schnittbilder huhu hause iggelheim
gemachte sachen im glas und eine ganz
normale verkauf szene haben wir die
japanese oyster mit wasabi ingwer und
hier
[Musik]
und ein tablet für dich den kriegst du
rib bekommen bei meinem ausland kurs 1 0
1 zuerst muss man die ausdauer von ihrer
schale trennen dann presst man ein wenig
frischen zitronensaft obendrauf ohne das
alles noch ein bisschen mit zwiebel
scheiße ab und herrn kerner als auch
schon in die fresse reingeschoben werden
[Musik]
die länder experience
mit news
es ist die blaue stunde oder sekunde
minute in lauschten der kunde bestimmt
wir bauen will
sie sind und sehen über ganz lande 50
euro meine london experian würde ich
eine geradezu ihm von 10 geben 5 punkte
- weiß extrem teuer ist auf dem heimweg
haben wir einen nussknacker gefragt wo
ist denn einen guten part gibt den haben
wir dann auch schnell gefunden wir haben
uns dazu entschieden den abend dort
gemütlich ausklingen zu lassen mit
apfelschorle natürlich lecker
apfelschorle und
läge im nächsten pub hat in der wohnung
darüber zu unserer überraschung die
hausband gespielt und was danach
passiert ist bleibt für immer ein
geheimnis
georges 1
wegen dem ganzen plastik haben wir uns
für einen kaffee entschieden aus der
tasse und dem man nicht so in pappbecher
krieg obwohl man ihn hier dringend okay
außer der ginger schott bin ich echt
braucht weil ich schon wieder krank
werte und oh wunder oh wunder es scheint
mal die sonne in london der letzte tag
mit sonnenschein
ich habe mir schon oft jetzt die frage
gestellt ob ich in london leben könnte
und ich glaube meine finale antwort ist
nein das ist mir zu voll
diese stadt ist einfach crazy es gibt
von allem alles ständig immer die
leckersten rahmen die kurzen leben aber
ich glaube wenn man das immer alles hat
dann liegt die insel die auch rein
ja das ist mein wort dazu und was darf
bei einer london reise natürlich nicht
fehlen
reebok ging in paris das erste haus am
standort des heutigen buckingham palace
über das aufzeichnungen vorliegen wurde
göring haus genannt
das haus das heute das zentrum des
gegenwärtigen palastes bildet wurde
jedoch erst 1703 von leon scherfig erst
der duke of buckingham enden roman b
erbaut
aber genug geschichte es ist der letzte
tag in london
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein bisschen christmas deco habe ich
noch gekommen
schön
[Musik]
seit ich mit aus
familienalbum die wohnung heute der
letzte abend
morgen geht es dann schon hause und
coole häfele
ja
damit auch noch